There was only one correct answer, which is this one over here.
The inadmissibility of the heuristic might lead down an exploration of the state space
that leads to the goal on a suboptimal path.
Let me demonstrate this to you.
Here is a world. Suppose our start step is here. Our goal is here.
The heuristic is super large for those states over here
and smaller around here.
The nodes will be expanded following the zeros around here and around here,
and the first time the goal is set occurs when we reach the point over here.
We never discover the shortcut straight from S to G
because of the inadmissible heuristic.
That renders point 2 correct, and as a result
A-star will not always find the optimal path as I have just proven.
Now, it turns out A-star will find the path if one exists.
It might find a suboptimal path, but eventually it expands
all the nodes that can be reached.
If the goal state is among them, it'll succeed to find a path.
Therefore this answer here was wrong.
Of course, none of the above is also a false answer.